recording in five four three
two one what's up you filthy [ __ ]
welcome to another episode of genius
brain podcast today we have a
a very interesting guest a business
partner of mine long time friend
also met this guy in k-town a while ago
but i don't remember
when i met him but i think he remembers
it more than i remember him
the man what are you trying to say what
i'm saying is
the man who uses way too many [ __ ]
napkins uh
started off as a a rapper
uh grew up in la uh k-town native
uh the man himself we have uh edric also
known as ed2
yeah maybe about by five people so talk
a little closer than mike okay
yeah man so what's up dude happy [ __ ]
new year yeah it's a new year it's 2019
man um
i can't believe i've been on this earth
for as long as i've been
but yeah i'm talking to the mic though
it's been uh
it's been adjusted too oh okay yeah
there you go yeah yeah yeah
um yeah i'm excited i'm excited for this
year and you know we we
just actually talked about what we're
gonna do in the new year um
and it's crazy to me to like see the
brand
grow like to have grown to where it is
now yeah
from where it started because we're
we've now been around for about a little
over a year right so if you guys don't
know the brand that he's talking about
is secret society
yes and uh i think one of the recurring
things that a lot of people have been
asking me because
i'm kind of like a serial entrepreneur
and i say about
so far the stuff that i've done it's a
pretty high success rate
um and uh secret society happens to be
one of those things so he's talking
about the uh the the clothing line that
we started up
yes so secretsociety.com scrt system
you know what it sounds like it sounds
like one of those [ __ ] uh you know
those east la uh
insurance commercials and [ __ ] i [ __ ]
love those dude
hey you have no insurance hey were you a
pedophile
maybe you are a rapist you have no
credit at all
well guess what come to gerardo
gonzalez's
easter egg auto insurance you're injured
yeah and then you got like those ads on
the back of the buses you know every bus
you see
yeah who's the dude that's on every ls
that deal with that legit mustache it's
like two two two
two two two yeah yeah the [ __ ] is his
name i forget what his name is
it's terrible because i've been seeing
this [ __ ] since i was a kid you know
but yeah he's he's a g he's like one of
the ogs i [ __ ] love those because
beca
in the beginning of those commercials it
always starts off as
that what happened to my car
um oh yeah but we started uh secret
society what's it been now a year two
years a year and a half
a little over a year a year and some
change um
and it feels a lot longer but yeah yeah
it's only been that long
and i think the thing that's been most
interesting to see
is like when it was just in the idea
stage
concept stage you know and we had talked
about it before we even
you know launched it the setup process
was a year right yeah yeah yeah yeah so
before anybody even knew what we were
trying to do
um you know that all the things we were
talking about doing and
and how we should go about executing it
um
and and creating this vision to to like
bringing it to life right making it a
reality
yeah um that process was
i don't know now it seems like a blur
and it feels like it was so
long but yeah i feel like each step
through the process
like seeing little by little like people
starting to understand it yeah people
starting to
really vibe with it you know and then
and then once the sales start happening
people starting to
actually buy it and wear it yeah that's
fascinating man yeah it's like you know
as long as i've done music too the music
process
never stopped being fascinating to me
right because when you think about that
process you're operating in the abstract
right yeah generally it's a
collaborative process you're in the
studio with a producer
maybe an artist you're collabing with
whatever everybody has an idea you guys
talk about it whatever
however it starts from whether whether
it's from a beat or maybe just an idea
for a song whatever
but everybody's thinking about this in
the abstract space
and then all of a sudden you guys start
kind of feeding off your
each other's energy right and then you
guys start cooking this too you know
everybody puts a little bit of their
ingredients in there yep
and then at the end of it you have a
song a finished song
and yeah like it it never stopped being
magical to me
and and it's kind of a similar thing
with with the
with the clothing thing because that's
something i wanted to do since i was 18
but music was always my first passion
and priority so
i never really pursued it and i'm glad i
didn't because if i started that [ __ ] at
18
you would have failed 100 you know
probably within the first year
i would have gone into it thinking oh
yeah i know everything i know how to do
this [ __ ] you know i will say this
though for you know
a lot of people out there who want to do
clothing um
and you're thinking like yeah maybe i
could do it and then you want to invest
money into it
[ __ ] don't do it you son of a [ __ ]
it is one of the most difficult things
i've ever invested into and tried doing
so mind you right before we did secret
society i started off with a brand
called go for broke
and uh go for broke was a brand that i
enjoyed
because i liked the message that was
given out to it and i think no matter
what no matter what brand i
attach myself to it has to be something
that resonates with me as a human being
right right and go for broke did do that
and go for broke was a huge lesson yeah
and a lot of people have been asking
um and i don't think like any of us have
really addressed it was
why did why did you shut down go for bro
go for broke wasn't shut down because it
didn't do sales
uh gopher broke did almost seven figures
it was on the way to do
us like seven figures that's how you
guys are doing well that's how well it
did
it wasn't because it was like oh it was
like the next level [ __ ] is because
we were creating a brand that empowered
people right
you know like when you wore this [ __ ]
you understood what it was about
and i uh obviously that happened because
a lot of people who are supportive of
what we were doing yeah and that brand
grew to something that we couldn't
handle
yeah that's what happened right it was
something that we didn't expect right
the company grew so big
yeah there was no way that we could run
this company
doing it bart giving it ten percent
right giving it ten percent joe giving
ten percent right
right right and we somehow have to run a
seven figure company exactly it was
impossible exactly
and so what we decided to do was decide
what was important to us yeah at the
time for me it was [ __ ] the film
right right i gave my whole year to that
yeah an incredible result yeah you know
so it killed it you know it was worth it
for me at the time yeah that you cannot
i could not do that film
and run that company run everything else
and yeah well i mean at the same time
too as
as rapidly as you guys were growing you
guys
none of you guys had a background within
the apparel business 100 we were just
trying to figure it out yeah
so you're learning along the way and as
you're trying to scale and grow properly
all these things the business operation
style starts coming in right
like how do we plan these releases how
many pieces do we get right what kind of
designs do we do yeah and then
if you don't have that experience it can
get overwhelming in a hurry
right and even if you are successful
you're like kind of scrambling like oh
[ __ ]
how are we gonna do this exactly and do
we gotta bring in other people now you
know do we got to bring in other talent
do we got to hire people
and then you kind of get it to get to a
point where it affects the efficiency
and kind of like the progress of the
brand yeah yeah man and it's just
it's it's a bigger thing than people
think that it is yeah anything that you
guys do
so no matter what and i know there's a
lot of young people out there who want
to be entrepreneurs yeah
and it's amazing i'm i'm really proud of
those people in that youth group
right that really do want to take that
chance to end that leap right but what
you do have
to understand is that there is a high
high rate of failure
exactly and you have to be okay with
that you have to be okay with the
process of failing and picking yourself
back up and trying again right
i have failed so failing is actually my
skill
like that's what people don't get right
no matter what dude people can talk
cocky about their basketball skills
i could talk about how many times i
failed and i failed way more than you
son
right all day right right like like
what's it called jordan got his three
point
i got my fail point son that's me you
know but
but you learn from it you grow from it
you know and i think the secret society
was something that
all those experiences that we that i
took i could take it back into this
company
right and learn to enjoy the process and
be
happy with not just like what the
company's about but also with the
products that we put out too exactly
because the first line that we did was
secret society which i don't think a lot
of people understand
it was all cut and so right that [ __ ]
does not happen a lot of the merch that
you buy
from these from these youtubers or
whatever yeah they're not putting that
attention and detail into it right
they're charging you a premium for it
right that's
the exact opposite that we wanted to do
with society yeah no and i want to touch
on
point two points that you you brought up
is um
you know going back to like having a
meaning for the brand and people really
embracing that right
um i think you know when we had first
talked about what secret society is
gonna be
that's something that you know we
communicated was that this brand is
going to be about community
it's not just about clothes and looking
dope right
we want to create a clothing line
where we say you don't have to have a
certain lifestyle to wear
our clothes because yeah remember what i
was saying that's one of the things that
i really disliked about fashion is how
polarizing it was you know whether it's
directly said or indirectly said it's
saying
you need to have a certain lifestyle to
wear or even afford our stuff
right yeah yeah yeah but for us it's
like no we're gonna give you value and
design
quality and price so that everybody can
wear this stuff
and you don't have to have a certain
lifestyle we complement your lifestyle
which is why we kind of focus on the
basics right something you could wear in
everyday life no matter
what your profession is what your gender
is what your age is
um and you know i think that's something
that people are starting to understand
more and more
yeah yeah um and another thing is the
whole
perseverance thing of being an
entrepreneur right yeah
i think it definitely takes a certain
personality
to take that path right it's not for
everybody everybody can dream about
being an entrepreneur
exactly exactly and like david was
saying you got to be ready to fail
many many times before you find even the
smallest semblance of success because
that might not happen immediately it
could be years as i'm sure
you know you have experience with right
and you know what it is too like i think
i don't know if a lot of people
understand this and i touched on this
when i was when we were i was talking
about it with z
yeah was that there is something to be
said about
people who buy things to wear it to say
i'm better than you right
you know right that's and that's what
we're touching on you know like
100 right we have brands like supreme
yeah like i appreciate what they do
right
like it's amazing what they have done
yeah they've even gone to that point
where they combined
high fashion yeah with [ __ ]
streetwear dude yeah they're one of the
first to ever do it it's [ __ ] amazing
you know but with a brand like that
we're
i think we're taking that risk where
we're saying you don't
have to be a person to wear this right
you're not going to fit into this group
just because you wear it yeah you know
and i think that
to the consumer's credit and to people
who follow certain brands
i think they're a lot smarter than a lot
of people realize exactly there are when
they pass a certain age they get smarter
they realize yo
hold on a second i'm paying 80 bucks for
this shirt or not a hundred dollars for
the shirt yeah
but it was made by [ __ ] gildan yeah
you know right
if you guys don't know gildan is like
the cheapest shirt you could ever buy
one of the blankets one of the blank
companies and it's the scratchiest [ __ ]
that you can buy
you know what you go no shade to gildan
though yeah yo you know
that's cool what i'm saying is like with
the gildan t-shirt
like if you want to know what a gildan
t-shirt is you know that shirt
that you that your parents would buy
from you from the swap meet right and
then when you uh
yeah and then when you would wash it it
would turn into a belly shirt
that that was a gilded shirt yeah and uh
a lot of your high-end brands that you
guys think are high-end that's what
you're buying
and that's the stuff that i couldn't
spend my money on yeah you know what i
mean
you know like i'm not saying you know i
think the the simple designs are dope i
love fashion basics like that's the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know if i could spend a
hundred dollars
i mean but you know that is a reflection
of where we are
at with culture and society too though
and technology yeah we're at a very
interesting space now where
you don't need to [ __ ] spend money on
martial can i cause
you the
this guy's a [ __ ] scumbag by the way
i don't know what he's talking about
i'm the most wholesome guy he knows
no but we're at a point now man we're
like you don't have to spend
any money on marketing it could just be
like one celebrity
wearing your [ __ ] and paparazzi catches
him with it and overnight that brand
blows up
right now i don't want to put any brands
on blast who
got big that way and i felt like really
dropped the ball
when they could have taken it to the
next level yeah but yeah we're just in
that space now where those things happen
but for me i mean maybe i'm a little
old-fashioned old school i still
strongly believe in the slow and steady
route because i feel like
when you're not ready for that type of
success that jump
then you're not gonna adapt to it you
know but
as you grow and things are growing with
it
you start to slowly adapt to it you know
you start figuring it out
um but yeah man i i agree dude some of
these things it's just pure hype
right like you know like you said 80
t-shirts on blanks
you know that's what i liked when i went
to um the fashion district in japan
yeah dude because you went to japan yeah
but you know right yeah it's
there's so many boutique stores yeah and
i saw all these
i've never heard of them before right
right it's literally their first
storefront yeah and you walk in
and the clothes are [ __ ] dope right
you know right now mind you
i was 300 pounds i couldn't fit anything
i mean
like that [ __ ] fit like a wetsuit
everything dude i put on a t-shirt and
you can see seal for every
bro you can see every ripple in my body
dude
like i was like i cannot fit these
t-shirts i will go back one day and i'll
come back even now i'm too big to fit
half that [ __ ]
right but a lot of that stuff is dope
because when i went to that fashion
district area they had a lot
of like boutique stores that were just
doing their thing right right it wasn't
a huge brand right but i could walk in
and i could tell the care
yeah that they had into this and i
[ __ ] with it and i could wear it
proudly yeah there was a
a brand that i like i mean they kind of
did like a a complete flip on it but i
bought a backpack and oh i remember you
got super into that brad now yeah i
loved it but i couldn't get it anymore
yeah yeah and uh it was this brand
called resquad and they yeah their their
whole thing was they they made like
old-fashioned japanese firemen [ __ ] it's
streetwear right i thought that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] dope man
i gave uh i had a sling backpack and i
gave it to my brother
i [ __ ] regret that [ __ ] so much i
want that [ __ ] back
just to let you know i want it back i
don't think you're using it you piece of
[ __ ]
um no but i think you know that is has
to do with like
attention to quality yeah you know and
and really caring about
what it is that you do right it's a
craft it's not just a means to
make something cool and make money right
like for example even with our [ __ ]
right with the first collection a lot of
people don't know this but
the fabric we were using for like the
coat the pants the hoodie
that's fabric that you see in like 500
600
items like a helmet lang item right but
we were taking that
and we don't have i guess the
burden of having to spend a lot of
marketing money
on promoting that right because we were
still in brand new brand at the time
yeah and so we get to use a fabric like
that
which you don't typically see in the
body of like pants
or a hoodie and then introduce it to
people and that's what i mean giving
them value in terms of
the quality the design and the price and
that was the cool thing like when um
it's hard because sometimes when
listen i understand that if i put out a
product right let's say
and by the way the reason why i like
doing clothing brands
is because i wanted to live outside of
me and um
that's a hard concept for a lot of
people to understand and they go
i don't want people to look at this
brand and say that's a david soa thing
i want to say yo that's secret society
right you know right that's right it's
it's
it's how it's going to live and the cool
thing is like what i think my biggest
joy of it was when number one i got to
see people who supported me wear it yeah
that was dope yeah and another layer was
people who didn't know me
they liked it and they got it right they
understood they were like yo
i know this fabric i know yeah i know a
coat that i could get like this
somewhere else
yeah that's worth way more yeah and
they're like yo what is this company
doing only selling it for this amount
yeah it's like yeah
and thank god i'm glad you understood
that right you know and you know i think
another one of those cool moments is
like when you're wearing it out
right and somebody who has no idea
where'd you get that yeah that's a dope
hat or yeah that's a really good shirt
yeah and it's like okay we're doing
something right here you know
i think i think we're we're chipping
away in the right direction
yeah that's why i say i'm so excited for
2019 because
all the work that we've done till now
we've seen progress and we've seen a
return
right yeah and now we have people
wearing it all over the world
right which is amazing to me yeah it's
like
the fact that you would spend that much
money on shipping you know to get a hat
or
to get a t-shirt yeah it means you
really wanted it right
and i hope that they're happy with what
they got because we definitely put in
the work yeah
to make that right um and so
by the way if you're gonna buy stuff
internationally and you know the
shipping is a lot
buy a little more exactly because i feel
bad yeah i know like we
we we have people who are buying like a
30 dollar hat and spending like 50 bucks
for shipping so it's like
at that point wouldn't you want to buy
like a t-shirt yeah at least
that's terrible too because it's like
you know for us too and you know people
don't understand they go
why can't the shipping be cheaper yeah
because
we would have to pay for it more and
then we make nothing literally
zero dollars off of it yeah the
international shipping it's the
calculated rate is just what it is we
make nothing off shipping sometimes we
still lose money on [ __ ] yeah boutique
stores
we're a boutique store right now if you
really think about it we're a boutique
store so
we have we we can't help that right now
right you know right and
the the like i know a lot of people
about yo how can i start my own brand
you can start it
you just have to understand what it
entails it's not just selling a product
it's a lot more than that right right so
we talked about right now
um branding you know and that's that's
one of the hardest things that you have
to do and yeah you know one of the
biggest advice that i
that i gave us too was you know if i
could ask you what our brand is in like
a few words you should be able to say it
right
a lot of people cannot do that yeah that
is one of the hardest things that people
don't understand so if i ask for example
if
anybody out there wanted to start
something right even if it's dave is so
comedy right
which that whatever that branding is my
branding is i call it
trash hillbilly asian comedy yeah
whatever that it is you know what i mean
it's unadulterated unfiltered opinions
right that's who i am as a person right
right if i and i ask other people who
who have asked me you know i want to
start my own i'm like cool man what are
you about they go okay well let me tell
you what
too long let me stop you right there
chief yeah
that ain't it yeah tell me what it is
where i can digest it right
right what's nike all right athletic
wear just do it just do it easy yeah you
know
and a lot of you out there might think
that that's easy it's actually very
difficult yeah
yeah very difficult right and it's not a
useless exercise like
it's important because it helps you kind
of condense
what the brand is into something that's
very simple and
once you do that that'll give you a
better idea of
okay this is what we should be focusing
on this is what we should be fleshing
out right
um and i think too man like you know we
were just talking about it in the car
about
not just starting a clothing brand but a
lot of these things that people get into
whether they want to be a musician
whether they want to be an
actor right a lot of the times they have
these false expectations you know and
like i was telling you i love seeing
people like
giving things up and sacrificing things
to pursue their passion
yeah and and love what they do yeah but
if you're gonna do that come with it
with a very realistic set of
expectations
yeah um in terms of like what's gonna
happen and what's not gonna happen
right and i feel like you have to accept
that it is going to be a crap shoot and
it is a lottery your chance of failure
is infinitely high yeah right whereas
your chance of success is so
minuscule that it's not even worth
mentioning 100 yeah that's why you got
to have the love and passion for it but
man even like doing music
i saw so many people coming in talking
about all this [ __ ] like all these
projects that they're working on or
whatever
it's like well what have you really got
to show for it i'd like don't tell me
what you're doing
because if if if it happened then i
would know about it
right you don't gotta [ __ ] sit here
and talk a big game like that's not
impressing me
you know but i don't know i guess that
has to do with like personality types
and security and all of that
people like talking more about what they
go what they're going to do right
actually
right right and that [ __ ] irritates
me man
for me it's like shut the [ __ ] up do
what you got to do
and your results will speak for itself
you know
i i don't want to hear you talk about it
save that [ __ ] energy and put it
towards what it is that you're trying to
do because
that's worth a lot more than the words
that are coming out of your mouth
you know you know it's funny because
like
a lot of the stuff i think because we're
older now we can articulate it better
with better words
but when i was when i was younger people
would say the same thing
but it would be in like four words or
two or three words which is like
test my gangster and that's really what
it is yeah
you know what i mean yeah you know be
about it don't talk about it so much man
you know exactly it's like kind of like
moving in silence and you know you know
by the way too
i feel like when a lot of people say
this it doesn't mean that you can't be a
proud of your accomplishments and you
shouldn't show oh
yeah go ahead absolutely but if you're
doing more talking than you are doing
then there's a problem
right right yeah well or you're what
you're talking about
isn't aligned with what your results are
yeah you know it's not matching
there's a discriminate discrepancy there
yeah that's what pisses me off it's like
dude just shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ]
up yeah and i don't care what you're
doing or what you're telling me that
you're doing
just show me yeah just show me right
yeah i'm not knocking on your hustle
you know i'm just saying get to work it
gets hard sometimes because
you know when sometimes when i'm on
other people's podcasts right
yeah oh so what are you up to yeah i
don't like saying it because it never
happened right right
i'm working on it right it hasn't
[ __ ] happened yeah let me tell you
this too like for example
um i was people were kind of confused
about with me working with kevin hart
right
yeah yeah they're like yo and this is
the phrase that i [ __ ] hate hearing
right now
because it shows the different mindset
that you these
these people that i've talked to who
what you have and what i have right so
they go
yo man you made it what the [ __ ] does
that mean you made
it yeah what the [ __ ] does you made it
mean right you know what did i make
you what did i make you work with kevin
hart yeah yeah but i don't got kevin
hart money
i don't have kev what does that mean am
i in a movie with kevin hart you know am
i doing shows with kevin hart right what
does that mean
yeah it means that he understood my
social media platform right he knew that
he i had value in that and he used it
and he walked away right
it's not like yo i didn't share a meal
with him
you know what i mean we didn't sit down
we didn't chop it up yeah yeah
you know what i mean yeah i came up to i
was like yo what's up bro i appreciate
you guys thanks man thanks man yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know he shook my hand
yeah
and the dude moved on yeah we did a
small thing i made him laugh
which was pretty dope like i had that
dude cracking the [ __ ] up right and
and that's really about it and then he
got on his forefoot leg feet and [ __ ]
[ __ ] went onto a jet and flew off
yeah i mean
you know it's a dope moment for sure
right let's not take that away you know
it's a dope moment but then it's like
to say you made it like saying this is
an
all-encompassing like i'm done yeah like
this is your
peak of the mountain now you know i'll
tell you this right now meg you know how
i know i didn't make it
i'll let you know when i didn't make it
i'll 100 say it i will be on this
podcast and i'll say listen to me
right i've made it yeah i'll say you
know how i know it's because if somebody
asks me they go hey
david what amount of money would you
take to suck a dick
i had that number in my head that's how
you know i did it
right because i still would suck a dick
for a certain amount of money
that number is pretty [ __ ] surprising
ed what is what is the number what is
the number amount
that you would take for money to suck a
dick man
that would have to be as a heterosexual
male as a heterosexual male and if
you're not a heterosexual male uh-huh
doesn't count
you lie that you don't have a number
you're just a [ __ ] liar
everybody everybody has a [ __ ] number
um
[ __ ] man like it it definitely is
greater than a million
because i feel like in this day and age
a million is nothing right say that you
have value on your life
50 000.
and a slice of bacon dude then a slice
of bacon
uncooked wow you don't even know that
that is
that is horrifically loved
i feel like it got even lower than the
last time we talked
you have any idea how much how much it
cost to start this podcast
that 50 000 would change my life right
now that's true
you know as you get older you got more
expenses and you know
you need more money to tell you
something else man let's say i sucked
the dick for a million right and
everybody says i can't believe
you sucked a dick you know blah blah
blah but let me tell you something real
quick all right when my kid is looking
at me with this little tonka truck toys
and he goes dad what did you do for this
daddy struggled that
he [ __ ] sucked a dick for you son or
daughter
yeah i'll tell you this right now it's
like daddy are you gay i am not gay
if i was it would have been a lot easier
yeah however
daddy stuck the dick yeah for your
college tuition yep because
i love you you can read because i put a
penis in my mouth yeah
and i'll put it to you like that don't
you ever talk back to me
don't you ever say don't you ever say i
didn't sacrifice for you if a kid
hears his if the kid hears those words
come out of his dad's mouth
you got nothing to say at that point and
i'm telling you this right now i
i i have rules to this too i've actually
thought about this quite thoroughly
oh my god you got rules all right i will
i will do it to a man
who is cleanly shaven i don't want sea
urchin spines in my eyes
and the watch the dick has to be washed
like freshly showered
freshly showered you have to get if
you're uncircumcised you have to
you have to you you you [ __ ] you
better you better make sure that that
turtleneck is clean
yeah and then after that you get about
five swipes okay okay but do you gotta
make him nut
nope no it's just sucking dick it's
sucking dick ah that's not too bad i
mean it's
you know as a straight i call it five
[Laughter]
and i want my [ __ ] in cash untaxed oh my
okay
i want it in cash can he like set a
stipulation where like you got to make
eye contact with
him when i can't do it
okay so you got to close your eyes and
do it he could record it yeah
he could record it he could but when he
records it yeah that goes at the 55 000.
and he could he could distribute it
freely he cannot distribute it unless i
make profit all right guys
you could distribute it but i guess 70
profit you get 30 okay and i want two
slices of cooked bacon
in your [ __ ] face oh that's some low
expectations man
i'm telling you man see this this is
this is
business learn from the best you heard
it here
and then you take that money and you
start your own clothing company exactly
that's right yeah and because you suck
the dick for it you'll work extra hard
you know you'll make sure that dollar
does not go to waste
exactly dude i got no shame man i'm all
about the future
i'm trying to well fifty thousand
dollars probably want to secure my
future no no not at all that'll buy you
like maybe a year i changed my number i
want it to be
a hundred thousand you can't yeah it
on the fly man i'll tell you this right
now i got some luscious ass lips
i understand my shit's luscious yeah
well you gotta you know use the
chapstick up make sure that i know i'll
need chapstick bro
easy dude
damn i'll tell you what man there is no
[ __ ] way i'm sucking dick for fifty
thousand dollars hundred thousand
no hundred and fifty thousand no it has
to be a million plus
if i'm gonna do yes it has to be because
it has to secure not only me but my
family you know
like like my parents you know my sister
you can't even buy a house with a
million exactly that's what i mean dude
i changed my number dude
i understand i forgot where i'm living i
thought i was living in the philippines
for a second
i thought i was i thought i thought my
name was r.j
and i was living in the philippines in
the philippines and i was going to buy a
place there
and i was going to live with my family
over there and i thought i was going to
be there for a bear
but i was not what's the new number then
my new number
is 2 million
it's 2 million because i need the first
million to buy a house and then after
that then i probably
would get um yeah then i'd be happy
yeah yeah i don't know man even two
million i feel like it's too low man
never forget
[Laughter]
you never will forget if you if you do
some [ __ ] like that well whoever that
guy's asking for it you'll never forget
either yeah you'll always look back to
the first time you got
the best blow job of your life i wonder
if there is
a dude out another heterosexual male
who's like so [ __ ] ballin and so
bored
that he's willing to make like an
offering like that
like yo man if you out there right now
if you're watching there's a dude out
there right now
you know what i take back the recording
party you can't
change some rules it's just getting real
because now it's getting real real
yeah now we're doing this beyond the
joke yeah yeah for two million dollars
if you get that [ __ ] i will give you
five whomps on your dick right now
change my life two million dollars cash
you you you come at me harry persian man
you come at me abdul
changed my parents life changed my life
right now
that's what i'm saying man 2 million i
don't think it's two million changed my
life i don't think so man cause
think about it dude like you get a house
you still gotta pay property taxes and
all that all right no
three million that's [ __ ] up it's
getting ridiculous
it just keeps going up man thank you for
this conversation because if i didn't
have that it would have been 50 000.
it would have been a steal i bet you a
lot of people were like dude we could
probably go fund me this real fast
and he would have to suck a dude's dick
yeah you know what it can't no gofundme
because i wanted cash
no gofundme go fund me i want that [ __ ]
in [ __ ] cash dude yeah of course dude
i i wouldn't i wouldn't [ __ ]
us dollars us dollar bills or 50 000
pounds which is more than american
dollars
i can't believe you started at 50 that's
i don't know
things have been tough amen
no matter how tough it is hey you know
how [ __ ] expensive this was
that's true how expensive this [ __ ] was
just hey this is dope though i will tell
you this people don't understand man
this is not a logo this is a an art
piece i i commissioned an artist to do
this [ __ ] was hard man like this was
amazing work that he did
and he paid a pretty penny for it that's
why he's he's stupid he's dumb you know
why you're dumb dude i would have sucked
your dick for it
for them for this
oh man and that [ __ ] is worth three
million dollars all right guys let's
just start a gofund for me don't you
[ __ ] work for dave not for the dick
let's just help him out he's in crisis
guys we gotta help this guy
out what the hell man he's in a very
very bad places yeah man and mentally
she's kind of rough dude
yeah i mean life life's been kind of
beating me down lately
other than that things are okay things
are okay no things are good man
but anyways back to the topic of
entrepreneurship
how the [ __ ] did we go [ __ ] throw all
that advice i gave you out earlier
and then start sucking dick
just start putting listings on
craigslist
a hundred percent man and then just say
you'll suck a dick for
fifty thousand dollars a hundred percent
yeah but we've i've um this was kind of
those weird things because i don't i
guess like sometimes when i talk about
like entrepreneurship yeah
i feel like uh i'm kind of like stunt
and it's not even that oh but i mean
that's your whole life though you know
what
it really is it's it's something that's
really fun for me
right right and the reason why i i don't
want to talk about it yet yeah and i'm
only giving stuff that i know that are
definitely for me
that have worked multiple times right is
because as you can see i'm still willing
to to give a [ __ ] to a hairless man
and that just shows that my the things
that i have invested into right now
haven't been um it's not there yet right
you know it's not retirement money right
you know what i mean right right and so
when i get to that point then we'll have
another podcast where the dick sucking
thing is out the window
now it's like now i'm offering the
[ __ ] yeah nobody suck my dick
dude now i'm offering it dude and on top
of that
even i'll tell you this though i'm so
much from the gutter bro i will still
suck a dick if i'm rich
for three point seven million people
so you're already wealthy now and your
number only just
i'm thinking about my grandchildren okay
i want to make sure that you want that
legacy money
yeah yeah you want that generational
money i thought about that too recently
with
the whole like i'd say
i don't want my kids when i do have kids
yeah to be like spoiled bro
absolutely man absolutely i i i'm so
[ __ ] ridiculous like i've already
thought this whole [ __ ] out i haven't
told mariel yet
but 100 i'm gonna trick them into
thinking that we're poor until they're
18.
no i honestly i have known people
who told me that they didn't know they
were wealthy until
they were in like high school right
because i don't know it could also be
because all the other people there
around are just wealthy and they think
that's the status quo yeah right
but they didn't really grasp like
oh man we are rich yeah we got a lot of
money and i
i think that does come down to parenting
you know and
all right let me ask you this when are
you going to buy your kid or your kids
their first smartphone i'm thinking that
they will have a pager till they're 18.
[ __ ] that i'm doing that i'm giving them
a dixie cup and a string
and you better [ __ ] you better have
that [ __ ] tight and then you're gonna
you're gonna twing it at the other point
and it's gonna vibrate over to me
when you need to get picked up that's
what i'm thinking they don't need to
follow my kids behind
you pieces of [ __ ] you're related to me
you're trash
i love them a dixie cup is a little bit
more okay no
i'm thinking though like on on some real
[ __ ] yeah i'm thinking that they're
gonna get
like um it's hard to say because
you know technology is progressing right
yeah but um
i would give them a phone yeah but
that's just not going to be a smartphone
though
yeah no that's that's what i was
thinking i was thinking all right
they need to have a phone because you
know that's what
we need to communicate especially or you
know yeah because i'll tell you this too
one of my actual goals is to financially
retire so i can be around for my kids
more
okay so they're like well how am i gonna
get picked up guess what [ __ ]
dad's retired i'm gonna pick you up and
i'm gonna [ __ ] love you dude
i'm gonna give you hugs and i'm gonna
give you kisses before you get up to
school i'm gonna give you verbal
affirmation yeah
i'm gonna do all that [ __ ] my parents
didn't do but like catch with you in the
yard what can you do i'ma chuck a
football at your face
you better catch that [ __ ] with your
teeth no yeah i mean i think that's
pretty interesting too man like because
that's part of the immigrant story
right like for us you know most of our
parents
tend to be like immigrants who came over
when they were
already adults yeah there are some
parents who came over like
went to high school here went to college
here so they're somewhat americanized
and they
speak the language pretty fluently yeah
like you know my parents are your
parents
yeah typical immigrant story right um
and that whole thing too man i got
nothing but [ __ ] love and
appreciation for that you know what i
mean
like just think about it man to [ __ ]
take yourself out of
where you grew up go to a country where
you don't know the language
right not only do you have to learn how
things are done here but you got to
learn how to communicate
i'll tell you this i don't have to think
about it because my parents shove it in
my face every day
right right they call me up on a daily
basis to let you know that same thing
you just said
like my mom will call me just to say
like hey do you know how hard it is like
what you just said right now
i heard it this morning i love what the
few curse words said
yeah cause she'll be like like most
people are like have you ever
think about it they shove it in my face
every day i don't have to think about
[ __ ] yeah
my mom makes sure she knows she goes do
you have any idea i have scars on my
stomach because of you you little fat
[ __ ]
yeah your mom's a david's mom is a
[ __ ]
g like savage man he i remember when he
let me listen to a voicemail
that his mom had left him it like it was
like three voicemails
she goes zero to a hundred real quick
like dave didn't answer the phone
because he was busy with something and
then it was like oh david hey you know
you know it's mom call me back
next one is like you [ __ ] little
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you think you are
not picking up
i was like is this like the second
message after the first one
it was three so the first one was
[Music]
you know whatever you know like hey i'm
not here you know pick up the phone
whenever you can
second was like
boy
right so what are you doing that makes
you so busy like when you
here get this phone call pick it up yeah
then the third one and
by the way if you want to guess the time
spent in between each call
30 seconds a minute it's not it's not
even like
yeah it wasn't even on like 20 30
minutes an hour later
it was like three minutes two minutes or
whatever
i will say this in between the times it
was less than 10 minutes so it's like
a minute three minutes or something yeah
yeah yeah like literally in that span of
time maybe 15 minutes passed
yeah and then the last one was like you
useless son of a [ __ ]
i remember that like she she says this
phrase in korean that i didn't realize
that
a lot of kids growing up didn't get
cursed out by their parents like i did
you know
yeah that that that i was shocked that
you your mom said some of the things
she said to you yeah she goes
yes
you know what that means that means you
[ __ ]
hanging piece of dog [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what she called me
because i didn't pick up the phone
within like six or seven minutes
and then like i called her back and i'm
like laughing my ass off right and i'm
like
yo who talks to their children that way
and my mom just says that's just how
mommy is
cause she's all chill now like after she
let it out
that's a little ridiculous yeah
maybe i went a little overboard but it
was necessary yo my mom like i remember
this one time so when i was a kid i
didn't speak korean as much and my
korean got better
as i got older because i started to
speak to my parents more right
and then my mom started realizing my
korean got better because i started
getting smart with her in korea
because before it was so basic yeah and
she would like i kid you not my mom
would call me keseki which means [ __ ]
so much i thought that was a nickname
i thought my nickname was [ __ ] growing
up like she was like
you know what i mean i think i think
that's you know
because you know you said like your mom
cussed at you and spoke to you in
a certain way that you thought that was
just normal speech in korea
yeah you know yo when i first came to
k-town i got [ __ ]
because i didn't realize how crude of a
woman she was dude
and i would say some [ __ ] that's super
disrespectful you don't speak to people
like that but that's how my mom spoke to
me so i assumed that that was normal
right and i called my mom up and i'm
saying in korean like what did you do
yeah
what kind of korean did you teach me
like people are mad at me all the time
and she's dying laughing she goes you
can't talk to people like that's how you
speak
what do you expect like that's how i
learned korean you know right
yeah you know i mean like for example
when you call somebody over in a
restaurant what do you say
that's like disrespectful way to say
come here
it's basically the verse i'm saying get
the [ __ ] over yeah yeah
yeah and when you say that to somebody
without context you're that means you're
pissed and you're trying to fight them
and i'm talking to like these old ladies
in these korean restaurants and they're
like and then one lady
corrected me she started laughing yeah
and because she speaks a little english
if you don't say that girl
yeah oh what do i say and she would you
go togia i was like
oh and i'm split you don't put it on the
kitchen
and i don't know why people were so mad
at me yeah and so the the ajimah
explained it to me she was like
that's not really right you say it like
this and she was laughing of course
because she understood my korean was
really bad
right right you know right so she got it
yeah you know her english was great
right
and that's why i was inferior yeah i was
so mad at my marriage
what have i been saying to people this
whole time now let me ask you this
are you going to pass on the korean
language to your kids oh mariel is for
sure
okay mario's she's a she's a poly guy
she speaks four languages yeah that's
right that's right uh her biggest thing
is that she wants her kids to speak
japanese and korean
okay okay so that that's her biggest
goal so yeah one of my goals this year
is actually to be able to speak japanese
at like a comprehensible level by the
end of the year okay
so i i have to follow up with that yeah
that's like some relationship [ __ ] right
right right it's it's something that she
wants
yeah and because it's important it's
gonna be important to me and you know
you love japan too so doesn't it i love
that [ __ ] dude
the the the one problem that i have with
jeff with the japanese languages
there's no curse words yeah they're
they're they're a very gentle creature
right
right right which is surprising for a
company that raped and pillaged our
people
like what the [ __ ] how are you guys so
nice and gentle yeah you
like you're the imperial army [ __ ] us
over and i'm you know
and we were having this conversation
where i feel like a lot of people who
are korean-americans can't relate to
that right right
and even they're like i know i have
friends in korea who can't relate to
that either they don't understand
they understand the history but they
still don't understand the hate right
i'm not speaking for everybody in korea
i think that's it's it's very
it's polarizing it's half and half right
right you know well i mean you know it's
understandable for the women who are
victims who are still alive yeah right
the comfort women yeah the kind of makes
100 right i mean they
still [ __ ] up when you think they have
every right to have a gripe
you know and be upset about it but you
know what we were talking about is
for us being the generation that we are
right yeah like
generations removed from when it
happened right
for us to first learn about that yeah
being a korean-american first of all
yeah but still having some sort of i
guess
a feeling of ties to the country right
or or korea even though you weren't born
or actually you were born there right
yeah yeah yeah in your [ __ ] face in
your [ __ ] face that's right
yeah no but yeah just as korean
americans to first
learn about that and then to process
that you know it was a weird thing when
i first learned about it because
i didn't i i definitely felt some
negativity
like yeah that could have been my
grandma 100 that could have been my
mom did your did your grandpa fight in
the korean war i
actually don't know you should ask about
that he passed away so both of them
okay well you're the worst prankster on
earth and you're a piece of [ __ ] i just
wanted to put that up there
you son of a [ __ ] yeah i'll ask my
parents yeah ask your [ __ ] parents to
trash human being
let me tell you something about my
grandpa my grandpa's dope as [ __ ] this
[ __ ] fled
hey he kept the real man no i talked to
certain people they're like oh my
grandpa he survived the korean war
yes carson he's telling me about he said
what about your grandpa yo my grandpa
got out of this little boat
and he took his family and he fled to an
island and he said [ __ ] this
and he went to an island and when the
war was over he came back and he was
like man that war was crazy huh
yo that's within my blood lineage dude
that's exactly what a davidson would do
that's where the dick sucking for fifty
thousand a hundred percent i know my
lineage dude man yo
grandpa shout out to you man because you
made that choice for a fact you would
have been killed because you're a [ __ ]
just like me is that the grandpa who
always like stretches every morning
still and exercises oh okay yeah that's
the ground
so fresh you didn't fight in the war
yeah and waited that [ __ ] out in poverty
yeah and he came back and he was like
yup i survived this yeah that's [ __ ]
thai dude
shout outs to grandpa so man shout outs
you gotta see his grandpa like he's
still a very limber man you know he
passed away oh you son of a [ __ ]
i'm bad i didn't oh [ __ ] dude
i did not know dude well he passed away
he passed away he was 98.
yeah i mean he got his money that full
was around before the car was made dude
yeah [ __ ] old guy yeah
he was so [ __ ] old man yeah now my
grandpa passed away at 90
so he got his money's worth too natural
causes dude like my grandpa
so when he passed away it was
interesting because i always say like he
chose when he wanted to go uh-huh
because he got to the point where he
couldn't make it to the bathroom in time
so we had to put we're like okay it's
time for us to put into it right because
we don't trust him to be by in the house
by himself right
right and this will say [ __ ] you i'm
dead and he died i was like this fool
just [ __ ] left when he wanted to
leave that's pretty interesting though
because like for me
i think i wouldn't want to live i mean
now
this is a thought that's based in my
reality now
with no wife or no family no kids right
but yeah
i would i don't think i would want to
live beyond the age where
i can't take care of myself you've got
to start now dude you're on a steady
diet of hot cheetos and [ __ ] [ __ ]
i know i don't know what you're talking
about you do nothing to preserve your
life dude
i know i think in your mind you think
because you eat preservatives it's gonna
preserve your life
that's what you think well it doesn't
even help that i don't sleep much either
so
yeah you went on that same tip though
yeah that's that's a whole different
thing yeah
and and i feel like at our age now sleep
is so important man dude it's [ __ ]
important man
i i feel like when i don't sleep now man
i i just can't function the way it's not
the same oh
yeah i just can't function the way i
used to you know it's like
before man i used to run on like two
three hours of sleep and i'd be okay
yeah now i do two three hours have to
fight him yeah i got a [ __ ] huge
migraine and i i can't function you know
so body's changing man yo you want to
hear something [ __ ] funny so like joe
the other day yeah
joe says like the most funniest [ __ ] out
of nowhere and this dude doesn't know
when he says funny [ __ ] like we're
having like a deep conversation about
relationships and [ __ ] and the joe goes
i don't know
it goes hey man now that you're getting
older do you real do you come less
what the [ __ ] i was like now bro
i think i've come to say it yeah i think
so yeah yeah
i was dying dude like what the [ __ ]
like where does this come into the
conversation i've been thinking about it
while this conversation was going on
he's like i'm gonna find this opening to
ask this question
that's like joe [ __ ] joe is the best at
saying [ __ ]
that nobody knows what the [ __ ] he's
saying man especially within a group
setting because he'll hear something
within a conversation yeah
and it'll spark his interest and then
he's already starting his own right
right right
i mean i think that though you know he
he's like in his uh own
like but it's sometimes just wild like
it'll be on some [ __ ] like
we'll be talking about finances then he
goes
cursive in the air yeah yup
and then we look at him we're like what
do you mean yup yeah right he goes
what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean dude you can't just
[ __ ] draw an imaginary rainbow and go
yup and then put a [ __ ] period at the
end of that imaginary sentence
and i'm supposed to know what's going on
right right that's [ __ ] funny man hey
people like that keep [ __ ] interesting
though you know
so like a lot of people don't know on jk
news yeah
if you if you guys watch like some jk
news episodes you'll see
us cracking up and dying and you'll see
joe's face
smiling smiling just because he feels
like he should laugh
because he just said something
ridiculous he's like oh i gotta be human
right now yeah
everybody else is laughing he's like why
is everybody laughing like i didn't say
anything funny he's like dude you just
said the most ridiculous [ __ ] dude
that's dope though man i mean it just
means you know he like processes his
thoughts in his own ways i dig it i mean
i'm kind of like that too you know
why i kind of go you're precise with
your he's he's on a different tangent
level dude
he's like on like our buddy steve said
it the best he's like the dude that just
had a boat on the duck and he just
pushed it off and he starts floating off
into the distance
that's that's that's joe dude hey i want
to be friends with that guy
whoever does that you gotta you could
you could yo i'll have you and joe just
do a podcast by yourselves you'll
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] dude
joe's the [ __ ] man yeah i mean i don't i
don't really know him personally but he
sounds like he's a funny guy
yeah man yeah i want to finish though
but go
back to the the whole kids thing because
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah cause i feel like
this
is imminent now you know it's in the
near future right [ __ ] right
so we you get them a regular phone
right yep why why not a smartphone
what's your reasoning i'll put it to you
like this though yeah um
i talk big [ __ ] now i don't have a kid
um there's a lot of people in my life
now
yeah that prior to me prior to them
having a kid yeah
and meeting their child yeah they were
all chest out right
you know talking about what they would
do right yo when i had this kid
this kid is not going to be like the
other kids all attached to technology
eating junk food yeah they're going to
have the right type of nutrition
eat the smart things and then i see on
instagram story this fool has a hot
cheeto in his mouth
with an ipad like this you know and i
asked them like yo what the [ __ ] man
like you were talking super big right
you were
you know chest out everything what
happened she goes it's hard having a
child
[ __ ] changes man it's so hard when they
want the candy they want the candy
you know yeah like the kid came up and
his eyes went green
and i just had they were killing me i
understand yes i need rest man
i just need him to shut the [ __ ] up for
a second so i give him the [ __ ] ipad
i get that dude yeah and that's why i
want to be retired
by the time i have a kid i do yeah
so i could just give them all my
attention no i mean for me man i don't
like no kid that's [ __ ] five years
old
should you all right
oh he's thinking about sucking that dick
[Laughter]
no coughing no
no reflex
[Laughter]
none of that no no kid should be [ __ ]
knowing
what wi-fi is at five years old you know
like i i hear kids coming into a
restaurant what's your wi-fi here oh
[ __ ] you kid yeah
it's like come on man like that's not
what you should be and here's the thing
here's
for me the reason why i want to kind of
delay the process of them getting smart
phones is because
i see what it's doing to like the kids
now i see what it does to me
yeah right right and you look at the
statistics right
it's pretty [ __ ] sad that millennials
are the most educated in history yet
tend to be the most unemployed the most
delusional in terms of like
i guess it's entitlement thing right
yeah
yeah they feel like they they deserve
more than they
actually deserve right and the most
depressed
you know why is that because you know
why because you have too many options
you're you're so exactly man you're it's
a blessing and a curse right
because by the way we're millennials too
we talk like we're old as [ __ ] but we're
actually millennials yeah um
we we have too many options right and
because we have so many options we have
we have time and with that time is a
luxury but with time for people who
don't know what to do with it right it's
a curse
right absolutely because what happens is
what am i supposed to do what am i gonna
do
yeah and i always tell people it's a
blessing
yeah and i'm somebody who thrives in
that because i actually
enjoy that right i like waking up and
knowing i have possibilities
a lot of people don't do well in that
yeah yeah you got to be real with
yourself it's hard no
yeah if you're not the type of person
who's a very good multitasker
chances are having too many options not
going to be a good thing for you yeah
you should practice it by
texting and driving
[Laughter]
you're going to get people killed don't
don't do that but
it's that thing of options because when
you are in a place in life
and you don't have money and your basic
necessities aren't being met
right that's your focus right the the
the joy
of life and all that other stuff yeah
that becomes
uh ancillary to your survival yeah yeah
but because your survival stuff is being
met yeah and you're listening to
podcasts or people saying you deserve
the world yes
king yes queen you deserve everything
and when you fall short of that
you know once again we talked about this
manage your expectations in life exactly
you set yourself
up for disappointment right because what
people don't say is this your life is
supposed to be hard
you're supposed to every like three or
four years try to figure out what your
next move is right people don't tell you
and set you up for success yeah when
people tell you you're supposed to be
successful they're actually setting you
up for failure right right
and you're not getting that yeah and
what i want to do especially when i have
kids is tell them
hey watch how many times you fail but
also watch how many times you learn from
it and you get better
right child you're supposed to fail
right you know right it's in our family
blood
right failure is is our skill
we're so [ __ ] good at it i'm so good
at failing you my son i'm passing that
down
you were gonna fracture your ankle
probably seven times
and you're not gonna even know how to
dance now go on my channel now go on my
child that's the world
and and and that's why that i think that
generation and raising that future kid's
gonna be tough because i want them to
understand
what the world is supposed to be right
and i don't want to get beat up
and be disappointed by basic [ __ ] right
right and i think
it's a little different for us because
we got to experience
both halves and what i mean by that is
you know part of our lives wasn't
dominated by technology you know
we [ __ ] went out we played outside we
played sports you know what i mean yeah
and then
life was simple right you need to call
somebody
you call your friend on the phone talk
to him for whatever you got to talk to
him about that's it go over to their
house they come to your house you meet
up outside whatever
and then we got to the point where
technology started to get really
integrated into our lives and it became
a an important aspect of every part of
your life right
for me what i noticed was it's like
the going to the options thing is that
it complicates things
right like yeah if you just know
okay this is what i gotta do then you
could
you might be able to have a better
chance of being focused on just that and
doing just that
yeah but now i feel like not only the
options thing
like kids get confused because they see
think about it man say you're a [ __ ]
kid somewhere in the midwest in america
right
and you're seeing the lives of these
influencers or these celebrities in la
they're always at the [ __ ] nicest
restaurants at the nicest places and
their life is just a [ __ ] blast
yeah you look at your surroundings
you're in a [ __ ] town with five
stores on one block
right how can you feel but inferior
like why the [ __ ] is my life like this
why was i born here
right why are my options or my reality
not that
you know and when you're going through
that stage where you're so
impressionable and so influenced and
like especially when you're a teenager
and you're seeing that [ __ ]
and i feel like especially girls you
know
that man how they [ __ ] over
sexualize girls who are 18 19 20 20 yeah
man
i'd be something like you know you drive
around i live close to a high school
yeah yeah
and these girls in high school yeah
because of like these makeup tutorials
and what they're selling them they look
like adults
high heels to [ __ ] school they don't
know yeah and i i'm like looking at that
i'm like you don't look like you stink
because high school kids think
yo high school high school kids [ __ ]
smell yeah you know what you smell like
you smell like backpack sweat
exactly regret yeah that's what you
smell like old gym shorts yep yeah and
so
and these kids are not smelling like
that anymore yeah you know yeah and yo
and
these girls too like they're being told
like yo you need to get a man with money
that's what i'm saying and i'm seeing a
lot of these young chicks go for a hell
of older guys
yeah dude it's like yo man old dudes are
not that great you got saggy balls dude
yeah man
yeah dude like sometimes two men like
i'll be going out to these shows and you
know like you have to realize too like
within the dms and stuff like that like
people slide into your dms right yeah
and you know i'll get some dms here and
there well they're kind of flirtatious
whatever yeah i'll open it and i'm like
young lady you are way too yeah excuse
me how dare you
and you guys know i was a pastor dude so
i'm about to try to evangelize this girl
right right i'm like excuse me
forsaken child yeah what are you doing
like i told you man i say this right now
dude i got
the body of christ but the mouth of
satan that's all dude
that's that's that's what this body is
dropping gems though yeah you know what
i mean
and and i look at some first of all dude
like you know it's so funny because
my my thing is i always say this man
like i always had to giggle my way into
the [ __ ]
because i didn't have anything else
going for me besides this mouthpiece
and so you'd be surprised man yo to any
of those girls that uh
like no joke hooked up with me when i
was 260 pounds thank you for giving me
that self-esteem
because you really did help me you
turned them into the man you really
today you really saw past all that
impurity on the outside not the same
like fat people aren't beautiful i was a
beautiful fat man
yeah you know i love myself dude but i'm
pretty sure when i was weighing down
on your hip bones like you you took one
for the team and i want to say thank you
very much
you you made me feel beautiful thank you
you guys made his self-esteem so high
that you turn him into a man who's
willing to suck dick for 50 000. thank
you 100
like that's never gonna go away man like
you you literally were the reason i had
no idea i was fat
like i had no idea i was like let me
tell you something big boys can't get
girls like this
that's why i'm not big and i should have
known when they stopped breathing when
we were having sex and i was killing
them
are you okay
yeah man no but no girl i feel like
that's 13
14 15 16 should worry about being sexy
man like that's not the time for that
you know there is a time in your life
where yeah you you should think about
that or yeah
or it's relevant but at 13 14 you should
just be a [ __ ] teenager just have fun
i feel like girls would just be ugly for
the first 18 years of their life
to build character right and then after
that you should blossom you know right
like dudes need a girl that can hold it
down
because guys first of all guys too man
guys you should be ugly as [ __ ] no you
know what i feel like when guys are ugly
as [ __ ]
they they turn to [ __ ] after they
start looking good yeah i haven't
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
and not to mention in this dating um
dynamic the guys are always at the
disadvantage you know the guys are
always the one pursuing
so if you're on if you're ugly on top of
that that you've got a really
uphill battle everybody i'm finding out
too everybody has a somebody man
um for sure you know i joke about you
know ugly whatever one
i know i'm not the cutest dude out there
man i'm cute though oh he is that's my
self-esteem kicking in right now dude
my self-esteem high you could call me
ugly as much as you want i'll [ __ ] you
i'm handsome dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] how ugly i am not in my
eyes or my mama's eyes i
[Laughter]
you know what i mean you know that's
that's that's that hard part man
especially being a young girl man i i
see it a lot on instagram
i see this stuff and you know guys are
so [ __ ] funny too man
there's some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] dudes i
don't give a [ __ ] man a lot of you guys
are like
well guys have social media influence
too yeah we do but you have to
understand too
i do believe that it's harsher on the
women's side yeah give them that at
least right you know nobody's
nobody's saying right that you as a male
don't feel those pressures to look a
certain way have an x amount of money
right yes you do have that pressure
right you know what i mean but when
we're talking about
this this is what it is yeah you'll be
that dude that tweets out a whole a
general thing
and then you're that one person that
fits that shoe and you and you get
attacked
right that's what the world that we're
living in right you know so when we say
these type of things about you know
girls
yes some guys go through that too yeah i
feel personally that women do
feel more pressure in that realm yeah
yeah you know because how do they get
attacked more oh 100
yeah because guys can cover that [ __ ] up
with money right because you got a
butter butt ass ugly girl she makes a
lot of money
doesn't really do much yeah but you have
[ __ ] uh
abdul rauf you know from persia with the
gold chain
with the with his chest hair sticking
through the gold chain and it gets
caught every now and then
with three teeth yeah but with the homer
simpson three strand here on top
pot belly yeah wearing some gator boots
yeah but he's a multi-million
or more billion multi-billion yeah
tycoon yeah and he has the nicest
hottest most vapid stupid women around
him yeah yeah you know yeah because
there's value in looking at a man
who has money and is quote unquote
successful it's like almost
inspirational right like to some people
i just have to be rich yeah i could get
that hot right
right it does not matter how it look and
and also too man like
you know going back to the girls being
attacked thing is like the messages that
they get you know like the dms that i
mean
[ __ ] dude i was like damn dude these
guys are [ __ ] crazy like the messages
that they're sending and those dudes too
by the way that
say that [ __ ] you ain't gonna do [ __ ]
yeah don't do [ __ ] you know what i do
with that [ __ ]
really little [ __ ] 10 year old tyler
what would you do with that [ __ ]
do you know what a [ __ ] looks like
exactly you little [ __ ] yeah
you know yeah it's so interesting
because they they talk this big game
that's what online does you could be
whoever you want to be online but when
it comes down to it
i'll put it i'll be i'll be even real
like this this is how real i hear
i arguably look at women on instagram
sorry mariel i look i look at women on
instagram right and i'm thinking man
dude that girl's so fine
yeah but if you came up you're like what
would you do with that [ __ ] i'd be like
i don't know
i have no [ __ ] clue yeah i have if
that woman dropped naked right i'd
probably cry
wait she's talking to me yeah what are
you doing what are you doing what have
you been through
who hurt you right that's what i'm
worrying like if the the woman that i'm
oogling on instagram over she comes up
to me she goes i have wanted you my
whole life yeah
the first thing i think is somebody put
their hands on you right and who is that
man right
like who hurt you who damaged you and
then she got naked and she's like
i want you to do nasty things to me i
wouldn't even know where to start
i would i would pray for her first
i would not know what to do let me hold
your hand my child i don't pray for you
yeah but yo man i think we've been doing
this for a good hour dude all right
yeah dude so where can they find you man
um
on instagram pretty much ed2 e-d-t-w-o
i've spot that multiple times dude by
the way
that's about it i mean i have twitter
and all that [ __ ] too but
instagram just instagram yeah check us
out yeah check out secret society
absolutely
um if you guys out there want to start
your own business i hope that kind of
helped you out
at the first half of the podcast yeah
the second half it went up
all different tangents man yeah but uh
yeah check him out ed too and i will see
you next time
on genius all right guys peace